this video is sponsored by
curiositystream
if you've seen dune already this clip
probably feels different from what you
remember
because i removed the score
[Music]
i've seen many people talk about the
film's imagery and it's very impressive
but the first thing that greets you in
this movie before you even see the
studio logos is sound
and i think both the score and the sound
design play a huge role in making denis
villeneuve's new adaptation of dune the
experience that it is i had a great time
watching dune and walking out of the
theater one of the things i was most
excited about was the film's score the
sound design and hans zimmer score add a
huge amount of scale and texture to the
world it's wild and completely unlike
anything else i've heard some of the
sounds he created for this score are
truly kind of terrifying
it uses layers and layers of voices
singing
chanting
whispering
yelling
throat singing
along with sounds from instruments that
genuinely look like they could have come
from getty prime
i fell in love with the score and what
it brought to the film so naturally i
wanted to watch doom without it
by controlling which of the surround
sound channels are active in a video
editor we can get a sense of what a
scene would be like without the dialogue
or without the score so i watched
through a bunch of scenes with just the
score no dialogue and just the dialogue
and no score to see what i could learn
about the score and the role it plays in
the film
for dune's score zimmer wanted to invoke
sounds that felt like they came from a
place thousands of years in the future
he didn't want the audience to ever hear
a full orchestra and instead wanted to
focus on using sounds that felt like
they came from the world of doom
typically in a score you might have a
melodic theme or a motif represent a
character or a place but for this
adaptation of dune zimmer leans away
from that he definitely uses certain
melodic or rhythmic themes
like the rhythmic drum hit
repeated throughout the film
in a variety of ways often prefacing
action or conflict
but zimmer focuses more on connecting
certain kinds of sounds to groups
influences or settings and then using
those sounds to invoke those things he
relates the insane grinding rhythmic
throb with the harkenin
he uses this whispery female chanting
for the betty jesuit
house of tradies gets more traditional
warmer sounds
i told my father i didn't want this
either so while duncan idaho has his own
little theme it also has a sonic
connection to the sound zimmer is using
for house of tradies as a whole
[Music]
and the desert and the fremen get higher
pitch sounds that invoke wind and sand
wind instruments like flutes as well as
vocalization that is distinct from the
whispery high-pitched singing of the
benny jesuit
[Music]
so this is where it gets really
brilliant i think dune is a complicated
story with a lot of different things
going on there are many competing forces
paul as a character is struggling
between different identities and
callings and associating different
sounds and instruments with different
ideas allows zimmer to actually bring
these different forces into conflict
within a single piece or melody
for example once we associate this sound
with the benny jesuit
and this kind of sound with the etredes
and the duke
listen to how these two ideas come into
play in the score during this
conversation alongside the dialogue
will you protect our son
with my life i'm not asking his mother
i'm asking the bene jesuit
when the duke addresses jessica as the
benny jesuit we hear the benny jesuit
sounds come in
will you protect paul
and then when she tries to reassure him
we hear the house atreides sound come in
but it comes in on top of the
benedezurite sound if zimmer had been
relying here on a melody to communicate
these two ideas this would have been a
lot more difficult but instead both can
exist within the same piece
simultaneously
another example is this scene the higher
pitched dentist drill sound represents
the pain being inflicted on paul's hand
by the box and the vocalizations
represent something being awakened deep
within paul these two forces can
actually exist and come into conflict
within the peace
so we have the desert the benny jesuit
the fremen house of tradies and various
prophecies represented in the score and
paul struggles internally between all
these roles and identities
[Music]
in the book we can actually read this
play out in his internal monologue but
in the film they decided to stay away
from any kind of voice over and so the
score helps bring that kind of
internality onto the screen and that's
not to say the score isn't utilizing
melodic themes but zimmer instead of
linking melodies to specific characters
with the exception of maybe duncan idaho
uses them more to illustrate plot lines
there are complementary melodic motifs
that follow paul throughout his journey
into the desert and because zimmer is
using sound for locations and groups
instead of melody he can evolve how he's
presenting that melody depending on
where paul is in his journey for example
we're first introduced to this theme
that follows paul's journey into the
desert with the warmer tones used for
house of tradies but there's also a
sense of mournfulness and longing as he
awakens from dreams of the planet
arrakis and the desert and then when
paul is learning about the fremen and
the desert on arrakis we get this same
theme but it's a bit distorted as if
we're only getting a vague picture of
the place
finally when paul is flying over the
desert we get the theme again but this
time it's no longer distorted it has a
new intensity and it's lacking that long
quality as if to say
this is my new home this melody marks a
certain element the plot and the way
it's portrayed sonically gives that plot
an emotional arc
zimmer uses another complimentary
melodic motif to represent pieces of
this same journey into the desert
look at how this moment
is linked to this one with both a visual
and a melodic motif
[Music]
while the soundscape of voices and
instruments that zimmer uses for each
moment represents the two environments
distinctly
these two complementary themes come
together in the final scene as paul
advances even deeper into the desert the
track for leaving calidan and the film's
climax are very similar but while paul
is in kaladan the vocals play more of a
background role while the track leans
more heavily on the aggressive
bagpipe style sounds that were
associating with house atreides but for
the film's climax in the desert those
sounds are still there but they fall to
the background while the vocals take the
lead
another example of how this plays out is
with the benny desert order while they
don't spend much time on screen they
play a huge role in the story behind the
scenes they're not visually present in
the destruction of arakin but we know
from the story they've played a part in
orchestrating this betrayal
so i love that their influence on these
events is felt through this scene
because of their inclusion in the score
similarly when the hunter seeker shows
up we're clued into the fact that it
comes from the harkonnens through the
score
before their involvement is revealed
through the dialogue the hawking agent
was cemented into that hole six weeks
ago
let's talk about duncan idaho and his
theme for a moment as i mentioned he's
one of the few characters that gets a
very blatant melodic theme
[Music]
but i think that this theme is used in a
clever way
almost every time duncan shows up we
hear his theme but when he's sacrificing
himself to defeat the sardikar instead
of hearing his theme which would seem
like the obvious move here we get a nod
to the fremen musically
and then when paul is going into combat
with one of the fremen we actually hear
duncan's theme
and i think this helps to illustrate the
interconnectedness of everything duncan
has learned from the fremen and he uses
that knowledge here in defeating the
sardicar and duncan's theme here is a
nod to the fact that paul has learned to
fight from duncan even though we never
actually see that in the film now i will
say if i have a critique here at all
it's that i think the score might be a
little overused in some moments i think
it's a brilliantly constructed score i
love how it sounds but there aren't many
scenes without any score at all watching
some of these scenes especially more
intimate dialogue scenes without the
score made me feel like it might have
been better to play some of these
moments with a little less score
ever since you brought him before your
reverend mother he hasn't been the same
he's distracted the film in many ways
feels kind of like it's rushing through
a bunch of setup when you drop the score
out of some of these scenes it slows
things down and gives the characters a
little more intimacy and room to breathe
and ironically i think doing this would
actually make the film score even more
impactful when it is used because the
intensity would only be magnified in
contrast to the quieter more intimate
scenes
but that's more of an issue with sound
editing than it is with the score i
think it's an incredible and inventive
score one that for me doesn't just help
make the film more exciting but actually
adds complexity to the story like denny
villeneuve han zimmer has been a
longtime fan of the book and i think his
knowledge of the material shows through
his work it's not just a score that
sounds like it comes from a distant
world in the far future it's a score
that takes the book's metaphysical and
mystical elements which take a backseat
in the dialogue and exposition in the
film and weaves them into the story
for me the success of this score is the
way it adds to the dramatic conflict of
the story and the way it takes part in
the world building sounding like it's an
artifact of the world itself
while watching the film to dissect the
score i discovered some cool ways sound
design and mixing are used in the film
like how they got the baron's voice to
just sound so terrifying
so i've decided to make a companion
video to this one that breaks those
elements down you can watch it right now
on nebula nebula is a streaming service
built and owned by creators and the best
way to get nebula and access to that
video is with the curiosity stream
nebula bundle which you can get for less
than 15 a year when you sign up using my
link below on nebula you can see bonus
exclusive content from me like my
breakdown of dude sound design or my
video about omar little's code from the
wire but you'll also get access to all
my usual videos early and without any
ads or sponsors when you sign up for the
bundle using my link you'll also get
access to curiosity stream where you'll
find a ton of educational and
documentary content if you're interested
in seeing very real stunning desert
visuals you could check out the
documentary africa's desert storms on
curiosity stream right now this bundle
is an amazing deal for less than fifteen
15 for an entire year you'll get access
to two streaming services full of
amazing content signing up and watching
on nebula helps support myself and other
independent creators like me click the
link on the screen to sign up now and
watch my video on dunes sound design
[Music]
[Music]